[Music]
joe you're talking about how the united
states navy might be compromised dude
okay so there's this thing called the
fat leonard scandal it's pretty crazy if
you type that up you'll probably see
documentaries and all this [ __ ] that's
going on i can't believe that this is
like big news right now because the us
navy has been basically infiltrated
and compromised and it could be the
whole entire navy if they prosecuted all
the people involved it could be all the
[ __ ] admirals right now like
leadership the whole leadership could be
wiped out but there's this dude called
fat leonard right and then uh trusted
source yeah he's a really fat malaysian
dude
or like chinese i don't know just my tag
is that your peoples yeah dude i'm
rocking with it but he basically it's
kind of like you know how the conspiracy
behind epstein is that he had the island
and he was uh uh
you know
getting all these world leaders to [ __ ]
young girls it's a real conspiracy right
yeah and then the conspiracy is they
were rigging all this stuff with cameras
and then they were blackmailing them
well
this
is not a conspiracy it's an admission so
fat lettered was doing that to the us
navy and then the way he got his start
is uh his family ran a business at one
of the ports out in malaysia or
indonesia and um when the
cargo ships and like you know these
fishermens came or whatever they need
food to resupply their ship and whatever
and that's what their family business
was well he had an idea of like you know
what
these big aircraft carriers military
ships they have like 400 people if we
get a contract with them we're going to
be like freaking millionaires right so
then he started getting you know
more relationships with the military
guys and they would you know sell apples
and lunch boxes and whatever right and
then
he started getting requests like can you
get like jerks can you get women can you
get whatever he's like yeah i could get
them and then so he started offering
whatever he could to the navy dudes and
then he went up the ranks and he goes
man you know if one ship can make me
this much money
how about
all of the us navy
and then so
he basically started providing all this
stuff and then you know the navy guys
were just like oh [ __ ] yeah this is cool
i like i like [ __ ] fat leonard i'm
gonna send my ships here and if they
didn't what he would do
is
he created like a house where he would
have hella orgies and and all that and
you would have it all recorded
yeah and then so it would start with the
gifts and all these things he made a
brothel in his port
basically had a mansion invited all
these naval like leaders to come in and
be like yeah you want to party here's
some drugs here's some women whatever
whatever you would record the whole
thing and if it got to the point where
they didn't comply with sending all of
the us ships to his port then he would
blackmail them basically so he could
have compromised all of them for other
reasons right because like what was
ending up happening is that um he wanted
his port to being the gas station the
pit stop for all the us navy so he was
motivated by greed if he was compromised
by like russians or whatever we could
have
had our u.s navy at the fingertips of a
different country he was actually um
using
what you're talking about i'm reading up
about it right now he was using it to
get locations of our entire fleet yeah
and he was actually directing them to
different ports so that he could build
the navy of all kinds of different
resources that's [ __ ] crazy they were
moving battleships because of this
[ __ ] just because of this one
guy yeah why is he coming out now or how
did this music this came out in 2019
finally but there was whistleblowers as
early as 2006 who all got like just
[ __ ] roasted by all the officers
joe's talking about in the navy as early
as 2006 so you had multiple
whistleblowers coming out saying hey
what else could i have done because
everyone's talking about in 2018 what
the [ __ ] why didn't anyone talk about it
there were whistleblowers who got
penalized
silenced maybe even murdered run out of
the navy yeah so so he just kept going
up the ranks because once he figured out
how the navy operated he's like who's
the man in charge that's in charge of
the logistics because his goal was to
get all of the ships going to his port
so then he wanted them
to direct the ships to where they're
going you know so so it was like a
business like and then he was he was
basically like handing them gifts maybe
even giving them a cut of all the money
that he was making and this is all u.s
taxpayer money because you gotta
remember like the the military is funded
by us so what ends up happening is he
can charge what he wants too so like he
could charge like 50 bucks an apple or
whatever outrageous prices he could pick
a price gouge we're forking out the bill
we don't know right
and then so the way that he got
compromised is one of the dudes that
were in charge of moving these ships
right high ranking dude uh i think he
was based out in like yokohama or japan
or whatever
but
his wife
knew he was cheating
and he was too [ __ ] bold about it
and then he was open about it in the
emails all this stuff and then they got
into a huge [ __ ] fight
huge [ __ ] fight and then she was like
you know what [ __ ] this [ __ ] she went to
the embassy ratted his ass out
and then the investigation started
happening internally they checked out
his email all his stuff and then they
they basically started tailing him which
led them to fat leonard
and then when leonard got [ __ ] caught
up they were like all right so what do
you want to do and he goes i'll squeal
i'll [ __ ] tell you everything he told
every like he told on every [ __ ]
that he was you know involved with right
and what he saw was there were a lot of
fall guys that got in trouble 31 people
criminally charged so far maybe
mid-level management to below not the
top dudes none of the guys who are in
trouble whatever right 440 people
including 60 admirals are under scrutiny
in the investigation but 31 charged so
440 people [ __ ] 60 admirals
and then so for him too he's the key
witness he has kidney cancer
and he's all like you know what [ __ ]
this i'm going out to the public so he
went straight to matt leonard yeah so
he's this is how he knows like he's he's
on a podcast there's a there's a
journalist that's like covering it all
and then he's all like at the same time
he's like hey if i'm gonna get [ __ ]
hit for this i'm also gonna die i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah i'm surprised he's
still a lot hey what's amazing is he
actually had a ton of credibility
because he of the blackmail situation he
was giving himself civilian
commendations by having the people that
he's greasing the wheels with i'll give
those to him so then he actually ups his
credibility that way it's crazy this is
great he's pretty [ __ ] smart like
evil genius [ __ ] dude so when he's on
that podcast he already has all these
commendations so he's not just some
crazy conspiracy theorist who like
worked with the navy he's like a guy who
the navy gave bestowed all these honors
to there's hella pictures of him with
top breaking anna like it's like so they
can't just excuse them and say like nah
this guy's not a crazy dude
yeah he needs fat leonard it's crazy
that he didn't fall off a cliff or he
didn't have to get into a car accident
or something
you know what he had a lot of leverage
because also part of the navy are the
seals right and if you have like a top
ranking admiral that has control over a
unit like that you can make a lot of
magical
coincidental [ __ ] happened to people
like this yeah maybe maybe um while he
was being internally investigated and
like he i think he's actually
incarcerated too
by the military
so like
who knows maybe it's too
risky for internal investigation to
catch on to it bart do you know of any
people who were like serving like in the
middle east and they were like
stealing gold or cash or anything like
that um like that george clooney movie i
think that's happening three kings at
the end of the day
all military is still made up of just
people
and people will do people things so i
know guys that brought um rocket
launchers and tires back into the states
how do they do that because that's how
they smuggled it they just bring it back
u.s military guys yeah they just because
before like uh now when they go over the
middle east it's like commercial
airlines they go through tsa all that
stuff right but before there's
infrastructure set in place
there is none of that so people would
just take back souvenirs that they want
dismantle whatever they have i take a
piece you take a piece he takes a piece
we'll reassemble it back over here we
have a friend that has uh saddam
hussein's personal glock because when
they raided
when they raided like the palace
um they were just going through
everything and before they have like
really detailed they go whoop that's
mine they don't have detailed rules of
engagement you know and it's just like
oh i found this
we attacked the target what are the
rules on this that everyone's like
okay like finders keepers the rules
that's the first
it says that right under semper fi
really small
semper finders keepers
have you ever seen that before
so it's just that i mean that happens
you know and like even i had buddies
that were stationed in okinawa
and they'll be able to bring chicks back
onto the aircraft carrier and they're
[ __ ] in like
bunks like this and they're [ __ ] in
little bunks you know like a japanese
pod like it's like those little and that
pod
and
and when i was in korea like because of
us russia relations like when you go to
the clubs you can and there's a lot of
russian chicks in korea you cannot bring
any russians back russian women are so
hot so far i know that's the problem are
they a honey pot operation
they're spies oh sexy spies [ __ ] ladies
and gentlemen
a bunch of russian chicks back on base
you know yeah that's like double
occasions these are just dudes or i mean
like people are just people too so it's
just dudes are just dudes is probably
easier to say yes dudes are just dudes
these dudes are more dumb do you think
they ever use the excuse that they
[ __ ] a russian chick because they were
trying to get information out of her
that would be hilarious you have to try
right you're like no sarge you don't
understand
i was trying to get information she was
saying to me yeah she's in love with me
she really likes me i got intel
do you know that caviar there is
actually from china no [ __ ] way
keep [ __ ] her man
holy [ __ ] sarge i got some intel we
should not drink this water 100 do not
drink the water
well inside information i guess i mean
it happens everywhere right like the dmv
lady stealing highlighters taking it
home just it just happens everywhere you
gotta have one mix up it happens
everywhere highlighters
my mom used to take [ __ ] like the
toner and she like extra toner they
didn't need from her office bro we all
know somebody that works in the
government
like building that we can get them
hooked up with because everyone had like
a dmv plug back in the day where that's
how you got people's addresses and [ __ ]
from license plates oh right
all my love but you kind of not answered
me because i said do you know of anybody
i know the guy that has on the things
i know
the saddam one but what about like
people taking like [ __ ] gold and all
kinds of that [ __ ] no that that's stuff
i'm not that's a higher pay grade huh
yeah the bart's like i can't talk about
that because i made a pact when we stole
the gold
not to tell anybody
and then we started jk films but there's
i mean there's a very uh what's the word
term of endearment called uh like oh did
you get that it fell off the truck oh
that's like this there's a lot of things
that fall off the truck that's the
expression oh i fell off the truck oh
okay that means i stole it
there's lots of things that fall off the
truck
a good answer good answer
what do you think about the term
military grade when you're like watch
you know you watch these uh these
commercials they always get dennis leary
to talk about four trucks he's like
military great and i'm like dude
everybody i've ever met who talks about
military grade talks about how much the
equipment sucks ass the new stuff's
pretty good it depends yeah like the new
stuff's pretty good
if it says military grade it better be
indestructible that's what it should
mean that's what it's supposed to be
like the stuff like the old alice packs
from vietnam they still work till this
day what's the alice pack yeah it's like
a metal frame pack like a rucksack that
you stuff all your things in and those
things is still one of the most
preferred ways to carry [ __ ] if they get
a vintage one and just use that or is it
like they keep making the same scene and
no in boot camp it's literally like 50
years old the one that you have oh wow
that's what i mean all the stuff in the
military is like old as [ __ ] and
antiquated yeah that's military yeah
toyota is a war toyota's of war
damn
that's military the perfect choice of
ride for isis the hilux the hilux tank
all right the hylix they don't release
that uh series in the u.s it's called
the 70 series right and they have them
all over the world except for the u.s no
i don't know why do you follow that guy
he's like a mercenary you know there's
like mercenary black water right there's
also mercenary mechanics what why so i
think he's like probably former special
apps wherever but he's like works on
vehicles so he'll hook up like a [ __ ]
forerunner and at the hit of a switch
the top pops up there's a [ __ ] turret
gun but he sells to both sides
it's just he's a real lord of war it's
just whatever he gets commissioned by so
if the special forces need some he's
like oh i'll make you like three land
cruisers and the [ __ ] the other the
other good guys i'll make you three of
them
yeah he'll make [ __ ] so he's like
selling to isis and he's just making
them so whoever's buying them is down
dude that paint job is sick a lot of
stuff that could fall off the truck
we had to get that fell off the truck
that's a human
what if you're nice guy you're carrying
capacity
are indestructible and honestly this is
a really good toyota this is a good game
of guessing how many people are on that
without like just looking at it once i
mean dude that you know that tire is
grinding up against that real real well
though yoda supplying insurgency since
1970.
if insurgents pick it you know it's some
good [ __ ]
because it's lasting longer yeah
that's true
well you don't see no tacomas out there
i'll tell you that man [ __ ] that's an
american car you know what i've always
wanted to see because i heard about it
was uh osama bin laden had a porn
collection apparently on his laptop
yeah and we never but we never saw him
what do you think it's in it that's a
fun game maybe lesbians debbie does
dallas
some old [ __ ] asia carrera asia maybe
mia maybe mia khalifa probably stuff
like that oh
that could make sense but it's filed
under like evidence like he's intending
on killing her or he's like bomb making
yeah
i swear to god it's bomb making in there
dude
it's something you normally hide he's
telling like one of his nine wives
maybe it's trying to make c4 i don't
know no no that's my that's my secret
suicide mission that's how you hide porn
you have folder bomb making
suicide mission
honor killing yeah
i don't want to have sex i'm going to
kill them yeah he's like 9 11 plans and
she's like why do you still have 911
plans in your computer you're like oh no
i need to delete it yeah i need to go
through this thing like
this is old [ __ ] you should accomplish
something yeah it's old [ __ ] sorry about
that
i got this 911 [ __ ] i competed man or
did you still have it you just bought
you bought this laptop three years ago
it's already over is there anything you
tell him 911
i don't know apple does this time
machine thing it just holds everything
yeah
i recovered it from the hard
he's like just better be one of your
[ __ ] other wives
this better be one of your wives doing
satellite downloads from the [ __ ]
cave it's like why is the bandwidth so
slow right now
[Laughter]
streaming
osama get off pornhub dude he goes to
google fiber's website it's like still
not available he's like
[Laughter]
where the [ __ ] are we gonna get this
thing that's why he's so [ __ ] mad all
the time we got new builds [ __ ] we don't
got new buildings we don't need an arms
deal we need a fiber deal
with some fiber optics in this place
yeah i feel like he's a bang bus fan i
think he would have been yeah i think
he's a pretty bang buster who's who's
not though
depends on the year something about that
bus yo about that something about like
just seeing people in the real world you
know yeah
picking up a girl
at a bus stop because it's a
conversation before it's like i can't
believe she got it i can't believe this
works every time and they just leave her
on the street well girls who are just
chilling on bus at bus house wanna [ __ ]
that's something people don't know
especially especially young men yeah no
one's taking the bus right no no no no
how many people you see on the bus that
are that hot they're just waiting for
the bank bus not the regular bus they're
just trying to get picked up
got it they always have a boyfriend they
always have a boyfriend so if you're
like 13 years old 14 years old boy i
hope you understand that that's how it
works
that's oh my god that's a great
introduction to sex oh my god yeah
that's the real world
yeah hide your porn in a 911 folder yeah
for all the americans 9 11 plans for 9
11 plans yeah yeah your girl's never
going to go in that folder why would she
why would she that she's a [ __ ]
terrorist
oh so you're looking for terrorist plans
that's how you can reverse it on that so
you can gaslight them yeah
oh
wow
i guess i know who a real terrorist is
now don't i yeah and then you pull your
pants up you're like
[Laughter]
i'm gonna be leaving now i don't need me
without terrorists
can i get my lotion with me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you